[Music]
hey y'all it's the matinee show once
again this week we are probably just
right gonna be renting stuff on the Xbox
various other things unless like shudder
or not Netflix add some new stuff see so
the first one that we saw this week we
actually runs it on Netflix this is a
2018 movie although it was labeled 2020
although it was labeled 2020 I think it
was it's weird because I think it got
like a very limited theatrical release
from what I could determine like back in
2018 but I hadn't heard of it and it was
marked as a 2020 movie so we're counting
it as new this is a Korean movie called
the witch it's either called the witch :
subversion or the witch : part 1 the
subversion yeah so this is as I said
this is a Korean film kind of a action
mystery sci fi revenge story I guess you
could call it kind of like the Korean
version of scanners and maybe like some
honor was that 80s serie stranger
stranger things yeah it was kind of like
an 80s style series about genetically
engineer kids that have them [ __ ]
superpowers and they're used they're
being trained as assassins but that's
just the premise the the story is really
good I thought it was cool
I didn't as well it's like this was
actually the same and I didn't know this
when we were watching it but it was
written and directed by a Park hoon Jung
and that's the same guy that wrote I saw
the devil which is one of the best
movies that I've ever seen in any genre
yeah also a revenge thriller like a
serial killer and a you know a detective
like kind of playing a cat-and-mouse
game this one is similar to that did it
actually this one reminded me a little
bit more of parasite in the sense that
it's a little bit cross genre yeah it's
like horror and action and a little bit
of comedy and like I think world cares
yeah and like a family drama because
like really like almost the first half
even I was the first two-thirds of this
is essentially like a family drama
that's setting up the main care
like the relationships that she has with
her family and friends it brought back a
lot of memories to me to having lived in
Korea you know to mean just the
countryside and the farms and the way
the mountains looked and the hills and
it's just and the culture and part of
the part of the thing is is that the
reason why the story's written that way
I think the Koreans are right in good
stories I've been a the directors that
we're seeing are really good and who
this director has he seen shining he was
leaving shining clues in the day it's
not that wallpaper so and you know
psychic kids with you know it's kind of
like they have the shining but I
wouldn't call it a knockoff in any way
really it is the premise isn't that
original but the story is original and
the characters are very likeable and the
reason why it's written that way is
because Eastern societies are very
family oriented so a movie is supposed
to be kind of like entertainment for the
whole family this is even in China it's
like that but Korea is a Christian
country so it has a slightly Western
value spin to it yeah I like it to me
it's kind of their what they're making
now is kind of like old-school
traditional movies that we were seeing
in the 80s and the 90s you know I mean
yeah the storytelling is very 80s 90s I
like it I do as well and like I said
they seem to be very good at meshing
genres in a way that seems organic and
doesn't seem or that they're trying to
mesh young Korea as a setting works for
that I say just like look at train to
Busan that's looking great and actually
the guy one of the guys that's in this I
was right that was the dude for it is
that because as soon as I saw him the
guy that plays his character's name is
nobleman yeah the actor's name is Choi
was chic but as soon as I saw him I was
like hey that's the baseball kid from
trying to Busan he was in parasite too
although I didn't remember that because
it's been like a few months in a train
to Busan which is a zombie flick there's
a baseball player kid who's
of like reluctantly has this girlfriend
who cobbles him and it's a Korean thing
gunner Korean boys are supposed to
resist they supposed to maintain their
purity yeah that's that's the [ __ ]
thinking behind it but in this movie he
plays a villain and he does a really
good job looks like a plugin he's a good
villain yeah it looks like [ __ ] gothy
kpop [ __ ] star like a goth k-pop
stars what do you look he does rather
and a bad guy yeah and there's a bunch
of other ones just like him there
running around assassinating people and
evidently this is like I was thinking it
might have been like a North Korean
experiment in Korea it's not it's an
American experiment in Korea or it's
American Korean joint that was the
impression that I got Barrowman there's
a lot going on in this movie it's like
it this is one of those movies where
kind of like parasite where it's kind of
going in one direction and then like
about in the middle of it or like about
2/3 of the way through because this is a
fairly long movie two hours in six
minutes I think it is then it kind of
like veers off in a different direction
not like a totally wacky way or anything
but you know we can't spoil it no and
what what I liked about it is that the
main character is a girl who as a child
ran away from this play the center where
they're making these things and she's
trying to keep it a secret from the
people that adopted her she got adopted
on a farm yeah it's like a Superman type
of thing yes she's like a shy farm girl
you know and her friend is [ __ ]
hilarious and they're in high school and
her friend is just this [ __ ]
hilarious kind of typical teen I loved
her in her head she's her litter bag so
she is like a little curler up there she
chases trying to chase celebrity and
playing online games and trying to you
know they make money and call her a
[ __ ] all the time dollar [ __ ] all-time
they're trying to scam give me that
[ __ ] yeah it's fun
I'll tell you what these new the new
Korean directors that we're seeing in
other words the good ones that were you
know I guess we're seeing the good ones
yeah they know how to write a likeable
character they do they really like
they bring you right into this [ __ ] you
know what I mean and like I said you
know talking about other Korean movies
that I really liked and you know the
same actions and this was then train to
Busan train to Busan I think this is
like one of the only horror movies it
actually kind of made me cry at the end
yeah because you gives you related you
got so into the characters mentioned in
train to Busan we also saw the animated
prequel yeah Seoul station Seoul station
it's good that's also Finnish utter
Russia and this one the end of this
movie leaves it open for a sequel so
that's also good because the story
wasn't totally told not everything was
explained it was a toy it was a full
story it's just that there was a lot of
unanswered questions it was gonna yeah
it could definitely and I think because
like I said the version that we saw this
is really weird because I didn't realize
that it came out two years ago and it
actually did really really well in South
Korea like it was the number one movie
for several weeks it did like a it had a
brief run in the US and actually made a
decent amount of money here even though
I don't really remember seeing it ever
playing here but um the version that we
saw that was on Xbox that we rented it
was just called the which subversion you
know what I mean nothing to do with the
Robert Eggers movie it's completely
totally different but then when I looked
it up like I'm Wikipedia and on reviews
and stuff like that site guys have
played it like the Fantasia Film Fest
like back in 2018 it was called the
which part one subversion so obviously
because I mean yeah like even when you
get to the end of this it's very obvious
that they're kind of making excuse for a
while I was like is this based on like
you know like a graphic novel or
something like that it doesn't appear to
be like I said because this was written
by the same guy that did I saw the devil
which seriously go see that Tom's got to
see that because he that's an excellent
actor limit yeah in this movie we saw
this off an Xbox and I think it was I
got the standard definition which looked
great on a smart TV you don't have to
get the HD version of this but the and I
think there was that super high
definition to the 4k I think that was
but I think just a regular definition I
think I paid what $2.99
it was 399 399 foreign aid and yeah it
was it's it's well worth the money you
get it off the Xbox you can put and it's
just just a good old-school movie now
when it starts I don't want to call it
old-school I want to say it's
traditional
storytelling yeah all right it's not
artsy fartsy in any ways it's
entertainment based the when it first
starts the town of the movie I thought
it was a little over the top it was a
little bit kung fu theater for the first
few minutes but then that tone kind of
went awake I started to normalize when
it went into more the family scene yeah
it kind of felt like like Superman like
I said Superman back home at the farm
yeah that was kind of the impression
instead of all American is all Korean
you know and that's that's what they're
trying to show you the tone is real good
I like the movie
it'll room if you like train of Busan
you'll like this if you like things like
a Kira you'll like this reminded me a
little bit of the Korean horror movie
the whaling as well which I don't think
you saw but yeah it's it's very very
similar to that it's like I said it's
you know if you saw I saw the devil
which is really really hyper violent and
like really gory and stuff this is not
that it does have that toward the end
like in the third act it does kind of
get violent there's like big violent
fight scenes and stuff but for most of
the running time it's pretty much like a
mystery drama I would call it you know
what I mean with like a little bit of
humor sprinkled in there so you know if
that sounds like something that you
would dig then you should definitely
check it out I mean I really liked it a
lot like I've really liked all the
acting performances only a criticism and
I think you said this as well was that a
few of the scenes like especially like
the talking of the exposition see it
went on slightly too long yeah probably
you know and they were kind of like
repeating information that the audience
like already knew and stuff like that so
they should have been like edited down a
little bit yes some of the shots
lingered a little too long and the Edit
could have been tightened a little bit
in a couple little spots but it didn't
ruin the movie no not at all just I'm
just saying that's like that's a pretty
minor like that shot went off for three
seconds it should have been a second and
a half yeah mostly mostly my criticism
was with like some of the conversations
like particularly between her yeah yeah
and some of it was like repeated like
something is up we already knew that
anime storytelling - that's true all
right which like I said it's an Eastern
movie and they have - they're catering
to that audience it's made for them not
us and they have slightly different
story telling styles you know what's
normal for there you know because you
know that there
our story tells those based in
Shakespeare and you know I mean and and
like three act stuff yeah they're
they're they're structures a little bit
different
but it still works yeah it's kind of
like a compromise between east and west
and the way they did things because that
felt Western to me it did in spots yeah
yeah still just a good movie okay I'm
watching I'm going like it's kind of
like scanners it's also kind of like a
superhero or super villain movie these
kids are genetically engineered there's
psychic but they also have like weird
physical abilities you know I mean like
they could move real fast run up walls
they're also kind of like a zombie in a
way but not really they're alive but
they can only really be killed by a
headshot yeah their bodies will heal
back up pretty quick just with body
shots and stuff didn't say I don't know
what happens if you cut him in half but
they're genetically engineered and then
they were trained from from birth real
early on to like kind of have bloodlust
and to be real violent you know that
they said they were in virtue they were
they were nurtured on violence yeah
that's right yeah everything him to the
dogs had to fight against dogs and [ __ ]
you know yeah yeah so this she'd
evidence she was pretending like she
forgot about that part of her childhood
yeah but she remembered it evidently
yeah
which they kind of explained that but
it's some of the action kind of looks a
little bit like the matrix er or a
superhero movie you know I mean running
up walls and yeah I mean I wouldn't like
I said I I don't think I would call it
an action movie all the way through
because it doesn't really like all the
violence and fighting and stuff isn't
really till the very end you know I mean
like the very very last scene where like
the big confrontation between the bad
guys and our but I mean other than that
like I said it reminded me of that
there's an interesting thing where and
I've seen this in like a lot of Korean
movies um you know like I said the
whaling memories of murder stuff like
that where it's just kind of like
don't want to say like ambling because
that sounds like i'm that sounds like an
insult and that's not what i mean i mean
that it just like it goes along in a
very kind of organic fashion yeah where
it's it's it's just kind of it's not
like a setup like oh we're setting up
here's like you said the three-act
structure it's like bad that right they
kind of it's just kind of like going
along with life and it might go off in
this direction and it might go off in
that direction and you're just kind of
like a long for the korea-japan they
kind of have that storytelling style
yeah but it's not so alien that you
can't enjoy it like you know I mean it
still ends up being a movie and you
still end up enjoying it either way but
I think the most extreme would have been
old Chinese movies old Chinese kung fu
movies in Hong Kong movies yeah there's
no structure they're just it's like
they're on [ __ ] some kind of drugs
and they're right it's just because they
had different expectations of how story
works yeah but yeah I liked it it's kind
of like like I said I thought it was
kind of like cross between a superhero
supervillain movie with scanners and
kind of like kind of run kind of like a
Kyra and kind of like I don't know it's
just it's just it's just good watch I
guess yeah and it's weird because we
just kind of came across it while we
were scanning through the 2020 you know
horror and action movies and I hadn't
heard of it before so I was like really
surprised that it had come out two years
ago not only that it came out two years
ago but that when it played in theaters
it opened second place after ant-man in
the wasp the Marvel movie yeah so it
actually ended up making I think it
ended up no 25 or 35 million in the US
which is like pretty good for a [ __ ]
yeah movie that doesn't really have any
it like for a movie that doesn't have
like a big you can see this movie
playing along the side of a Marvel movie
it's darker yeah like a horror movie but
not really well kind of like the matrix
the tone is similar to the matrix
sometimes the combo yeah but just the
fight scenes yeah it's hard to explain
it was pretty bloody it was kind of
graphic in certain areas almost kind of
like a spy movie - yeah you know
almost kind of like a spy James Bond
movie it's just Kevin yeah it's
everything yeah it was really
interesting had some like stuff with
like the [ __ ] Korean equivalent of
like American Idol show or whatever had
that kind of aspect to it the teen girls
yeah and then I'm hanging out I like
Spectre or James Bond type [ __ ] going on
but you know it wasn't light when it did
that oh yeah you can somehow he
sometimes you can mash that kind of [ __ ]
in there it just seems chintzy yeah not
believable it was believable within the
context of the story it didn't it does
yeah it's it's almost kind of like in
the way maybe when I said before that it
was like ambling or going off and it's
maybe it's more like but I feel like
those types of movies are more like a
tapestry yeah you know what I mean like
there's all kind of different stuff
going on but it's all kind of related
but it's like a real yeah life you know
what I mean of these so maybe that's why
the characters seem like real people and
you can relate to them here because they
seem like more they were going for a
young audience too you could tell
because it was so it's about cute people
yeah cute villains heroes to you know I
mean yes so that's what they were doing
but yeah this was definitely good Jamal
for that yeah that's what people want to
see yeah yeah and I mean definitely just
for kind of coming across this and just
watching it on a whim cuz the trailer
looked cool yeah you know what I mean
it's actually this actually ended up
just like that you can just see the
trailer on Xbox it's good yeah yeah and
this I'm sure it's available and other
streaming is probably not that long so
check it out
you
so for this second movie we saw this
week this is another one that we rented
on Xbox and another one that we didn't
really know anything about other than
just kind of seeing the trailer and
trace the poster looking medical trailer
looked good and I was like that looks
interesting and it was Italian movie and
it it looked good and we saw it and it
was impressive I liked the movie I
actually really liked it it's
interesting because like I said this was
one that we didn't really know anything
about we just kind of saw like the
poster looks kind of cool and the
trailer looks cool so we watched it then
later I found out that it kind of has I
don't know if it has like low scores or
like low reviews but it's like half and
half but then like I went and watch like
other horror channels and stuff like
that and like someone were saying I
don't know why like the ratings are so
low because this is a really good movie
yeah they're full of [ __ ] now I was
available movie it's got what it's got
that gothic Italian Baroque looking
style to it you know I mean it's very
modern well I don't want to say modern
they're using modern technology to give
you that old-school kind of Gothic look
to things gnome Tama yeah I mean there
this is doing it a lot better than the
old Italian horror movies from the 60s
and the 70s this is like it looks like a
high-budget movie it does ya know what I
was gonna say that maybe maybe the
people that are giving it a bad rating
are ones that kind of like more modern
horror jump-scare kind of focus on kids
because I feel like this is the type of
movie this is like a pretty much
old-school ghost story
if you dig some stuff like the woman in
black or crimson peak or something like
that then this will probably be right up
your alley it's not like I said it's not
a super super original story or anything
but it's just like a really good-looking
old-school ghost story that doesn't rely
a lot on jump scares no yeah this is not
like one of those might is that it
Michael Beit it makes those damn no no
who is that that make James want what
games want he produces that much name of
those things that we the conjuring
universe like the extended kanji this is
kind of like the opposite of the day
Kanzi michaelbay did transformers I
think didn't yeah that's us that among
other things yeah yeah it's kind of like
the opposite of that you know I mean it
doesn't that doesn't have that kind of a
little budget mainstream feel that the
Contra universe has even though I like
conjuring universe yeah I like it but I
like this better it's it's more stylish
and it's a ghost story but you know I
don't want to spoil it there's another
monster in there too yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] cool yeah yeah don't want to
spoil the movie but yeah I mean
basically a premise and everything is a
good idea
it's an Italian movie but it is in
English yeah it was shot in and it's not
dubbed like you know your old-school
Italian movies where they were just dub
everything in English it's it's everyone
speaking English even the people that
are Italian in the movie because they
used apparently a lot of locals to be in
the movie and they're speaking English
you know with very thick Italian accents
and the main characters are British so
this is an English language movie but it
was shot in Italy and all the crew was
it'll it was Italian the directors
Italian and it was actually shot in
Messina yeah it looks great the
locations a fan yet like the houses they
found like the cemetery it's like it
looks kick-ass it reminded me a little
bit of a cemetery man if you guys have
seen that and it's like I really really
need to need to review that one of these
days because I love that movie but yeah
so basically the setup is you know it
starts out in I believe it's in 1908 yes
before some Italian earthquake yeah and
there's like this this area of Messina
that is kind of like all these kind of
upper-class Brits that live there and
there's this one particular family and
they live in this big mansion and they
have this kid named Peter who is a
horrible horrible horrible [ __ ] of a
child's ex psycho he's killing myzel
animals that [ __ ] yeah I'm like nailing
Abba trees and all those other mamas
that were protecting him and [ __ ] like
that
[ __ ] heat I don't know should we he
kills this boys dog very early in the
Muny the the boy was like an Italian
like I guess they called him a peasant
he's a good tag he called him a peasant
he called him what he worked his father
worked on that he was like a landscaper
yeah he was a son of like one of the
hands that [ __ ] yeah that maintained the
place and this boy got revenge on him by
burying him alive all right now totally
deserved I have two guys as a kid desert
I think it was a [ __ ] all right price
stuff in there shouldn't spoil but
anyway this burial of this kid caught
causes a haunting to happen in on the
grounds of this damn house yeah and then
it goes into modern times where an
American no he's British he's British
okay British dude and his daughter
move move into that area to do so like
some like archaeology yeah he's an
artist there they're working on them
they're working on restoring this
cemetery and a bunch of paranormal stuff
happens which leads him to kind of like
discover this house and and what had
happened with this cruel Peter and then
he comes face-to-face with like the
ghost of cruel Peter and weird [ __ ]
happens his [ __ ] daughter's death and
she's involved in this and really
there's a lot of [ __ ] can't be spoilers
just it's a good movie it's a very good
movie of its kind it pays homage to a
lot of movies of the past that were like
this but I think it tops a lot of misses
this movie is way above average for this
kind of movie I was very surprised
actually way above every it's like I
said it's the visuals on of it are
really really cool I especially like
this sort of I guess it's I don't know
if this is like an actual thing but the
thing that's like the bishop's fear that
they used in it that she used to like
try to contact ghosts and stuff it's
essentially like a Ouija board but in
like sphere form but like the way they
utilize that like in the visuals was
like really really cool but this is just
a gorgeous looking movie only thing I
could ding it for is some of the scenes
are like a little dark yeah so you could
I can't really see what's going on in
them but it is kind of scary in a way
yeah I'm not sure if they did that
because they didn't think the special
effects were good enough or if that was
just a choice that they made or
something I'm not really sure probably
the specialist
X weren't that credible so it's better
to just kind of make it real dark and
leave you guessing it does eventually
show you what it what it is yeah but I
think it being kind of vague might have
added to it I think it did too because
it left a lot to your imagination now if
we were in a totally dark room and we
saw this movie maybe we'd be able to see
a little more clearly
that's it wasn't totally dark I mean we
yeah we watched it at what like seven
yes seven thirty or some like that it
was still like a little bit sunny we try
to kind of keep it dark in the room
rough like it doesn't always work out
like but I rented it I think what was it
$6.99 I think it was six days
$6.99 which is a little bit more than
yeah a little bit more than some of the
other ones some of the other but I think
it was worth it in price and I got the
standard definition standard definition
look great on a good TV yeah I can't
really tell the difference I'm like
because you can pay a dollar more and
get it in HD but you know man I was kind
of like Widener's his movie for you know
yeah you get a stunt cheap an ass
well like I said I can't really tell the
difference you can't really tell the
difference so it's like you might as
well save a buck cuz you know since
we've been renting these it's like I
don't want it to like add up to like
zillions of dollars it's like a dollar
here and there it's like it's gonna add
up but this one now as I said if you're
wanting like a super action-packed like
scare fest or something like that this
is probably not the movie for you but if
you're really into like old-school ghost
stories that with that kind of like old
gothic like almost like Glos kind of
look like I said if you like like I've
this really reminded me a lot of the
woman in black more more the remake I
think than the original I've been here
real quick I've got a piss-poor
attention span you do all right
movies got to be interesting in it or I
won't give a [ __ ] this movie did get me
interested I didn't have to struggle to
stay to stay yeah especially with this
type of movie which right as usual story
oh you saying well don't expect
action-packed actually know a lot of
[ __ ] happened in the movie well that
yeah if for for the genre a lot of ghost
movies they're kind of slow for me and
I'm I get bored this one it did take its
time but it was interesting throughout
the whole thing especially the setup at
the beginning of
how evil this kid is yeah so early on it
hooked me I was like well what the [ __ ]
is going on oh man
yeah yeah [ __ ] that kid the ghost of
that kid all right
and then obvious then I thought it was
just gonna stay like that knit and then
it added a new element on top and there
you go oh no wonder this kids such an
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so it's not an
action movie but it's not it's also not
boring a lot of stuff happens in it and
it is interesting even for a guy like me
who has a hard time paying attention to
somebody else's story
I'll pay attention to my own stories
like a [ __ ] with somebody else
like yeah okay yeah yeah so don't don't
don't don't think that's boring based on
Jenny's description cuz they me being
[ __ ] average Joe you know Joe Joe
slinging dick whatever you know listen
be like that sounds boring to me you
know it's not boring if I if I could if
I like to eat probably like it I didn't
find it boring at all was important I
mean and you know well like I said it's
kind of hard for me to judge because
this of all horror movies I love all
kinds of horror movies but my favorite
sub-genre of horror movies is like old
ghost stories like wanted house type
stuff so I'm already inclined to like
this type of thing I just you know I get
paranoid because I know how some people
and like I said this is not like a super
high rated movie and I feel like maybe
that's because people are so used to
kind of you're more mainstream like just
there or you know it's a more slasher
more gory type of thing and this is not
like that so that's what I'm just
telling you it's a lot more atmosphere
yeah a lot more stylish it's a lot more
like gothic horror yeah and it's like an
Italian gothic or almost kind of like
you know something you would it's this
is what they wanted a horror movie to be
like back when they were making hammer
flicks back in the 60 yard it to look
and feel like this yeah and with today's
technology you could do it so it's kind
of like an Italian and an Italian
interpretation
of a British classic style yeah that's a
good way of putting a good way to put it
and I will say that I actually and I
said this to you last night
I liked this a hell of a lot better than
a lot of the more recent like conjuring
universe movies they seem like the nun
and lyuritis yeah I liked this a lot lot
but I joked and it there was a few times
in it where you thought there was gonna
be a jump-scare but then they didn't do
it and I was like ah thank you I like
thank you better Edelin Hansell I like
this better than a lot of the horror
movies we saw in a theater today lately
this year she's correcting my English I
just got woke up saw it not really woke
up but I was you know I mean I haven't
really been talking it takes them a
while to get you know but uh you know I
came out of my [ __ ] vampiric slower
so I talked myself out of that okay it's
a good flick it's a good thing yeah it's
um it what I was saying is I'm pissed
that I didn't get to see this in the
theatre am see didn't didn't give didn't
give this a release yeah you know
there's money involved in [ __ ] grease
and palms of [ __ ] I mean you're getting
your movie in a theater I'm glad to
pandemic hit they're forcing me to
[ __ ] rent these movies off my xbox
cuz I didn't know that there were
there's a bunch of that bunch of horror
movies on there that they did not show
at AMC Theaters that according to the
trailers looked a lot of them look
better than the ones that we saw that's
a chair yeah so you know I'm a call [ __ ]
I'm gonna call shenanigans this one
apparently got a brief theatrical
release but I think it was about a year
ago like back in 2019 although it's I
don't know if it was that's the weird
thing it's like at the end of this like
thing that I was reading about it it
said it was released theatrically and on
VOD platforms on Friday March 13th I
don't know if that was this year because
on the Xbox the year of release says
2020 yeah but apparently it did some
like it premiered it like some festivals
last year because I saw a couple reviews
of it of people that had been at
like you know some film festivals and
they had seen it like a year ago but I'm
presuming that they mean that it was
released theatrically and at VOD this
year yeah you know what I mean bro it's
just we didn't get to see it because
like I said all the theaters have been
closed and I don't even know if they
would have shown it anyway because we
didn't we never saw a trailer for it I
don't think not that I remember but yeah
it's definitely it's for rent on Xbox
I'm sure you can probably run it on
YouTube and maybe I'm I don't really
know out of this installation of retro
matinee matinee show this is the if
you're gonna be only watch one this is
the one you see yeah this is the one I
would definitely recommend the most out
of the three that we're gonna do this
week yeah all right
you
all right and the third and final movie
we saw this week yet another one we
rented on Xbox this one is called the
ascent yeah do you see this with like
$2.99 yeah in an SD and
standard-definition standard definition
and still enjoyable it's what they did
with this this is an exorcism movie okay
it's kind of like a highly glorified
episode a very high budget episode of
the haunt of a haunting of a haunting
the acting in it is suck a slightly over
the top everything is [ __ ] big it's
action-packed there's always something
[ __ ] happening in this movie and
there's it's a the the characters Arcana
in a way stereotypical even though they
have weird spins on them this was a
great watch I mean this was very
entertaining very entertaining you're
not talking about some kind of a high
budget masterpiece this is a low budget
movie but it's done well got forgot
practical effects the house that it's
set in is [ __ ] creepy spooky looking
it's got some celebrities that you might
gonna recognize from other movies from
like John Carpenter movie Jason Peter
Tatum O'Neal wait a mone laughter the
damn [ __ ] she wasn't it at much she's
not that like kind of a cameo but and
it's just constant constant occurrences
constant action and the exorcist priest
guys just doing is he's not dialing in
he's [ __ ] shooing up the scenery
through the whole [ __ ] movie and you
just if this is a movie that you just
won't get bored watching it oh yeah it
was super fun it's just and it just
moves along it's only it's an hour and
27 minutes long moves right along moves
right along the deadlock around the
director telling about the director he's
like oh yeah PR ET oh yeah he's a
Singaporean he's made some other stuff
he made like Cloud Atlas I think and he
made a curse of Sleeping Beauty and so
he's made like a bunch of like indie
movies and stuff and like like you said
there's some big stars as Peter Jason is
in it Robert Kazinsky who was in [ __ ]
Pacific Rim and I think he was in
Captain Marvel he's like the main
character
during this now as I said it's it's not
a super original story in the sense that
it's an exorcism like it's a demon
possession and there's some interesting
twists but yet there's like there's some
kind of interesting twist and I guess I
can it's not really spoiling them cuz
they set it up prettier setting up er
Lisa but so the main character it's cut
it's a single dad and his son Mason
which is also my nephew's name curious
but yeah so he's got this son he's
suffering from schizophrenia which is
one thing because there's the whole
thing where you know he's not sure if
what he's seeing like happening with his
son is real or just imagining it or he's
like maybe my kid has inherited the
schizophrenia and it's starting to
manifest so there's that whole
uncertainty then you also have the thing
with the Exorcist like priest father
Lambert he's played by a you know but
Peter Jason yeah he doesn't dial it in
man he [ __ ] gives you your body's
worth yeah and yeah and there's like
another element of uncertainty
introduced because he at the beginning
of the movie he's getting out of prison
for inadvertently killing a child during
his previous exorcism so that so there's
kind of these other factors at play that
make this kind of more interesting than
your standard exorcism movie now like I
said the it's it's very action-packed
there's kind of a cool the way they shot
it was kind of cool it almost looks like
you know when you do when you're it's a
3d movie but you take the 3d glasses off
and it's like that weird like red and
blue little lines right like you've been
droppin acid yeah it's a little bit like
that so it looks kind of like that like
this because they're trying to convey
like the kind of you know the guy like
you and he's kind of seeing things and
like the way yeah and so they have that
and then there's like the demon I guess
it's the demon and that almost kind of
looks like that looks som like altered
states David Cronenberg looks like kind
of like it looks kind of like a crab had
a baby with the thing from from beyond
yeah like the from beyond thing yeah big
spider
kudos for the fact that this isn't CG
that's a real costume yeah or maybe a
puppet it's hard to tell what it is yeah
but it's a practical effect and at least
it looks like it's there yeah that's a
lot of things I like that at least it
looks like it's there so she ECG you
know it's not there but this thing is
actually there and I would I would much
much rather see shitty practical effects
than it ECG yeah yeah oh yeah but hey
this is not an artistic masterpiece this
is a good entertaining movie basically
what you have is you have an exorcist
movie almost kind of given to you in the
format of an action movie kind of you
know what I mean yeah I would have I
enjoyed it as an adult sitting there
watching it you know with a drinking me
you know [ __ ] gone yeah yeah you know
this is funny I would have loved it even
more if I was 16 14 15 16 I know this I
would I would be I would swear to you up
and down that this movie was better than
The Exorcist if you're a 65 was fit 14
valve ha the extras just man this is a
real cuz that's the tone yeah just
because it's very like kind of
high-energy over-the-top it's out of
whack II that's not wacky no that's not
we're saying we're just saying that a
lot of it the acting is a little bit
over the tab it can't be we just you can
tell you get the actors are like okay
let's get this [ __ ] over with yeah kind
of tell it and they're not that I think
the director getting did a good job of
getting a performance out of them it's
almost kind of like a stage performance
yeah yeah it's kind of stages stage II
but not in a bad way not in a bad way is
just it they're putting on a show you
can tell that each one of these actors
is putting on a performance
yeah that's but it seems natural in the
context of this movie yeah it's only way
I can only way I can describe you got to
see it for yourself is cheap so it was
weird because when I was watching this
this is like maybe totally out of left
field
reminded me of another movie that I saw
like a like a few years ago on Hulu
called the butterfly room that had
Barbara seal in it and the acting in
that movie I think a Heather Langenkamp
was in it as well but the acting in that
movie like reminded me of the acting in
this one where it's like well it's like
everyone is a little bit overdramatic
like over-the-top and stuff but it seems
like a deliberate direct Orido it does
it seems like they're doing it on
purpose it it seems like they're having
a lot of fun making this movie it did
seem like yeah because it did seem like
especially like some of the characters
that were like you know villains and
stuff like that they will really like
having a good time like play it out like
I'm so evilly I think what the deal was
is that the way they were they were
making a paycheck and they were putting
on a good show for the kids that's what
it felt like to be well in there it
they're like we're not making Citizen
Kane yeah just like into their exorcism
movie yeah and it's just you know it's
not completely original it has like some
curveballs in there but it's you know
it's not reinventing the wheel or
anything like that States just [ __ ] it
we'll just have a good time with it
you know we've got like a blobby crab
monster we've got like all these [ __ ]
trippy like eyeball effects and stuff
like that they got like I said I got a
kid that's little kids [ __ ] killing
it with his possession [ __ ] routine
yeah can I also just say oh this I have
to say this this premiered actually
latched like last October like late
October at the Toronto Film Festival I
don't think it got a theatrical release
or anything like that but it's kind of
been going around and the trailer was
really good and I feel like there was a
lot of hype like surrounding it because
of the trailer also because of the
poster which is kick-ass yeah I really
refer my graphic designer standpoint
that is an awesome poster it's very very
yes you at least want to take a look at
the trailer I don't think this got very
good reviews like on IMDB and all no I
don't think so either but you know what
[ __ ] them that's not what this movies
for like like Jenny said this isn't
they're not making Citizen Kane here
they're trying to put on an an
entertaining exorcism movie yeah yeah
and they succeeded in their try was
wildly I'm saying their truck you from
getting bored yes this is far better
than what Edward
it's it's a read the movie makes sense
it's constant activity constant action
there constant performance there you can
tell that this guy that this director is
trying to give you your money's worth
you bought a ticket he's gonna show you
some [ __ ] and it worked to me work I'm
saying and like I said he did he had
enough little twists in there that it
kept it interesting it kept it fresh
like I said I you know I see that it's I
don't think all the reviews were bad I
think it was about half and half which
is generally what happens with most
horror movies I think it's about half
and half because you know some people
love it some people hate it most of the
reviews I saw from other my usual other
horror guys most of them seem to enjoy
it and said about the same thing it's
like yeah the acting is a little over
the top but it's like you know it's not
doing anything super original but it's
still like a really fun like
entertaining movie I think some visually
pretty cool some people have different
expectations when they see a horror
movie some people really want to be
scared
all right I can't you can't do that to
me at my age you can gross me out yeah
well yeah that's much easier can't
really scare me but you can't entertain
me with a movie like this yeah so at
least this movie did that and that's
always like this oh you asked for yeah
and honestly I'm pretty forgiving when
it comes cuz I love horror movies and
it's like so I'm so I'll give like the
benefit of the doubt to a movie where
maybe some people would do please stupid
or whatever like I'll give a lot of [ __ ]
you know I'm patient with a lot of stuff
cuz I really like the genre and there's
some movies I've seen that I really
really hated but like you said I don't
really think you can ask for anything
more it doesn't have to be those [ __ ]
brilliant thing ever made no or do
something completely mind-blowing and
original as long as they take something
they put a little new spin on it and it
entertains you then that's really all
you can ask some people can't stand a
goofy horror movie I like a goofy horror
movie you know like like Evil Dead good
example alright this movie is not one of
those it's not given to somebody have
that town it's but the thing is though
is that you can tell the way there it's
performed by the way they're presenting
it the people that are making it are
conness
lately tongue-in-cheek behind is I can
tell I could yeah I can tell you what
mostly just having fun with this if I
could pick but yeah but it's not a
comedy that's not it's not play it
doesn't know that play go calm know this
wouldn't like I said I would have not
picked up on that vibe it at 1415 yeah
16 but now as an adult I'm like I see
that the performers are [ __ ] going
slightly over the top on purpose yeah
there have this like tongue-in-cheek
element yeah they're over selling
certain things yeah yeah yeah it's not
like it's not like that in the sense
that it's like they didn't care they
just phoned it in it's quite the
opposite yeah they didn't care about it
yeah yeah but you could tell they were
having a good time making it yeah yeah
which like I said that's that's pretty
[ __ ] cool well probably what is the
directors going like more energy more
yeah more more you know yeah like that
but I get more but more so that's
probably and I think that's I think
that's the exact tone that the [ __ ] I
think that's the tone the director
wanted so you could me because I'm
interpreting any either way the younger
audience might be always [ __ ] was
[ __ ] fireman older people would be
like yeah I say oh yeah so definitely
this if you like exorcism movies you
need probably the idea this one too it's
uh I think it's for rent we it was $2.99
right yeah for like 10 bucks what do you
got to lose standard-definition maybe
three days it's like $2.99 something
like that but it was well worth it yeah
I I had a really good time with it and I
wasn't even that drunk or anything I
only have like one drink last night so I
wasn't like so wasted that anything but
yeah check it out if you like that kind
of thing
[Music]